[Music]
Jamie Lee Curtis speaks out against
child molestation in Hollywood the 59
year old actress penned a powerful essay
for the Huffington Post on Sunday in
which she reacts to co-star Eliza
Dushku's claims that stuntman Joel
creamer molested her on the set of the
1994 film True Lies quote she had shared
the story with me privately a few years
ago I was shocked and saddened then and
still am today Dushku was only 12 at the
time and played curtis's on-screen
daughter Curtis went on to explain what
compounds the difficulty here is that
the stunt coordinator in question was
literally in charge of our lives our
safety over the weekend dish coupe
detailed her story in a lengthy Facebook
post Cramer however has denied her
claims in a statement to Deadline quote
these are outlandish manipulated lies I
never sexually molested her I'm sick to
my stomach it's not true I think she's
making this up in her imagination this
is all lies lies lies lies I treated her
like a daughter we all looked out for
her True Lies director James Cameron
also reacted to the news at the
Television Critics Association press
tour on Saturday
calling Dushku very brave for speaking
up
[Music]
you